I don't know why it's on my mind I want
to pick an old grievance so Game of
Thrones season eight I'm not gonna
defend it don't worry about that there
is however one aspect that everybody
makes fun of and it is dumb but not for
the reason everybody says so you know
how eventually when the night King shows
up and they attack Winterfell and Tyrion
has all the children and women hide in
the Crypt and everybody including Peter
dinglish points out that's a stupid idea
because the cryptos where a bunch of
dead people are in the night King can
raise the dead to fight for him but the
thing is that's not why that scene is
stupid the reason that scene is stupid
is that yeah the Dead start attacking
them in the Crypt
but they're all in stone caskets and
keep in mind these are not white walkers
these are the zombies the power of them
is in numbers but how is a dead
emaciated rotted body able to punch
through Stone it's not stupid because
there were dead people there it's too
because they shouldn't have been able to
break out